some people see the thing that they want
and some people see the thing that
prevents them from getting the thing
that they want it's as if an entire
generation is standing at the foot of a
mountain they know exactly what they
want they can see the summit but they
can't see it the male people put
harley-davidson logos on their body to
say something about who they are
corporate logo ain't no Procter &
Gamble's tattooed on anybody's on
passion is the feeling you have that you
would probably do this for free you know
and you can't believe somebody pays you
to do it he's an author speaker and
consultant who writes on leadership and
management he joined the RAND
Corporation in 2010 where he advises on
military innovation in planning he's
known for popularizing the concepts of
the golden circle and to start with why
he's simon Sinek and here's my take on
his top ten rules for success rule
number six is my personal favorite I
make sure to stick around all through to
the end for some special bonus clips and
as always if Simon says something that
really really resonates with you please
leave it down the comments below and put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired as well
let me tell you a story so a friend of
mine and I we went for a run in Central
Park the Roadrunners organization on the
weekends they host races and it's very
common at the end of the race I'll have
a sponsor who will give away something
apples or bagels or something and on
this particular day when we got to the
end of the run there were some free
bagels and they had picnic tables set up
and on one side was a group of
volunteers on the table were boxes of
bagels and on the other side was a long
line of runners waiting to get their
free bagel so I said to my friend let's
let's get a bagel and he looked at me
and said that lines too long and I said
free bagel and he said I don't want to
wait in line and I was like free bagel
he says not let's it's too long and
that's when I realized that there's two
ways to see the world some people see
the thing that they want and some people
see the thing that prevents them from
getting the thing that they want I could
only see the bagels he could only see
the line and so I walked up to the line
I leaned in between two people put my
hand in the box
and pulled out two bagels and no one get
mad at me because the rule is you can go
after whatever you want
you just cannot deny anyone else to go
after whatever they want now I had to
sacrifice choice I didn't get to choose
which bagel I got I got whatever I
pulled out but I didn't have to wait in
line so the point is is you don't have
to wait in line you don't have to do it
the way everybody else has done it you
can do it your way you can break the
rules you just can't get in the way of
somebody else getting what they want
that's rule number one
performing under pressure whether it's
me or anybody else is the same you know
I have the same pressures as anyone else
there's time there's performance there's
financial I mean there you know there's
deadlines my pressures are not unique
the situation's may be different or you
know but but everybody has the same
kinds of pressures but what I found or
what I find fascinating is the
interpretation of the stimuli if let me
let me explain so I was watching the
Olympics this lesson relax and I was
amazed at how bad the questions were
that the reporters would ask all the
athletes and almost always they asked
the same question whether they were
about to compete or after they competed
were you nervous right and to a tee all
the athletes went no right and what I
realized is it's not that they're not
nervous it's their interpretation of
what's happening in their bodies I mean
what happens when you're nervous right
you
heart rate starts to go your you know
you should get a little tense you get a
little sweaty right
you have expectation of what's coming
and we interpreted that is I'm nervous
now what's the interpretation of excited
your heart rate starts to go you become
you're anticipating what's coming right
you get a little sort of like tense it's
all the same thing it's the same stimuli
except these athletes these these
Olympic quality athletes have learned to
interpret the stimuli to the rest of us
would say is nervous as excited they
also the same thing no I'm not nervous
I'm excited and so I've actually
practiced it just to tell myself when I
start to get nervous that this is
excitement you know and so where when
you used to be speaking for the large
audience and somebody say how do you
feel I say a little nervous now when
somebody says how do you feel like
pretty excited actually
and it it came from just sort of telling
myself no no this is excitement and it
becomes a little bit automatic later on
but it's kind of a remarkable thing to
deal with pressure by interpreting what
your body is experiencing as excitement
rather than nerves and it's really kind
of effective it makes you want to rush
for is rather than pull back and yet
it's the same experience I talked to so
many smart fantastic ambitious
idealistic hard-working kids and they're
right out of college they're they're
entry-level jobs and I'll ask them how
is it going and they'll say I think I'm
gonna quit and I'm like why they say to
me I'm not making an impact I'm like you
know you've been here eight months right
they treat the sense of fulfillment or
even love like it's a scavenger hunt
like it's something you look for my
millennial friends they've gone through
so many jobs they're either getting
fired I mean it was mutual or they're
quitting because they're not making an
impact or they're not find anything
they're looking for they're not feeling
fulfilled as if it's a scavenger hunt
love a job you find joy from it's not
something you discover it's not like I
found love here it is I found a job I
love that's not how it works both of
those things require hard work you are
in love because you work very hard every
single day of your life to stay in love
you find a job that brings you ultimate
joy because you work hard every single
day to serve those around you and you
maintain that joy it's not a discovery
but the problem is this sensitive
patience it's as if an entire generation
is standing at the foot of a mountain
they know exactly what they want they
can see the summit but they can't see is
the mountain this large amove Abul
object that doesn't mean you have to do
your time that's not what I'm talking
about take a helicopter climb I don't
care but there's still a mountain life
career fulfillment relationships are
journeys the problem is this entire
generation has an institute
sense of impatience and do they have the
patience to go on the journey to
maintain love to feel fulfilled or do
they just quit and on to the next
dumping on to the next ghost and on to
the next in the 18th century there was
something that spread across Europe
eventually made its way to America where
pole fever also known as the Black Death
of childbed basically what was happening
is women were giving birth and they
would die within 48 hours after giving
birth
this black death of childbirth was the
ravage of Europe and it got worse and
worse and worse over the course of over
a century in some hospitals it was as
high as 70% of women who gave birth who
would die as a result of giving birth
but this was the Renaissance this was
the time of empirical data and science
and we had thrown away things like
tradition and mysticism these were men
of science these were doctors and these
doctors and men of science wanted to
study and try and find the reason for
this black death of childbed and so they
got to work studying and they would
study the corpses of the of the women
who had died and in the morning they
would conduct autopsies and then in the
afternoon they would go and deliver
babies and finish their rounds and it
wasn't until somewhere in the mid 1800s
that dr. Oliver Wendell Holmes father of
Supreme Court justice Oliver Wendell
Holmes realized that all of these
doctors were conducting autopsies in the
morning weren't washing their hands
before they delivered babies in the
afternoon and he pointed it out and said
guys you're the problem and they ignored
him and called him crazy for 30 years
until finally somebody realized that if
they simply washed their hands they
would go away and that's exactly what
happened when they started sterilizing
their instruments and washing their
hands the black death of child bed
disappeared my point is the lesson here
is sometimes you're the problem we've
seen this happen all too recently with
our new men of science and empirical
studies and these menace finance who are
smarter than the rest of us until the
thing collapsed and they blamed
everything else except themselves and my
point is is take accountability for your
actions you can take all the credit in
the world for the things that you do
right as long as you also take
responsibility for the things you do
wrong it must
be a balanced equation you don't get it
one way and not the other you get to
take credit when you also take
accountability I spoke at an education
summit for Microsoft I also spoke at an
education summit for Apple education for
my at the education summit from
Microsoft I would say that 70% of the
executives had spent about 70% of their
presentations talking about how to beat
Apple at the Apple education summit a
hundred percent of the executives spend
a hundred percent of their presentations
talking about how to help teachers teach
and how to help students learn one is
playing this way and one is playing that
way one is playing finite and the other
one is playing infinite guess which one
gets frustrated so at the end of my talk
at Microsoft that gave me a gift they
gave me the new Zune when it was a thing
and let me tell you this thing was
spectacular
it was the most elegant piece of
technology I'd ever used the user
interface was incredible the design was
spectacular I absolutely loved it it was
easy to use and it was bright and
gorgeous infant I didn't work in iTunes
which is a different roblem so I
couldn't use it but but it was amazing
and elegant my god it was elegant so I'm
sitting in the back of a taxi with a
very senior Apple executive sort of
employee number 12 kind of guy and you
know I like to stir pots so I turned him
I said you know Microsoft gave me their
new zoom and it is so much better than
your iPod Touch and he turned to me and
he said I have no doubt conversation
over because the infinite player
understands sometimes your head in
sometimes behind sometimes your product
is better and sometimes it's worse the
goal isn't to be the best every day the
goal isn't out to outdo your competition
every day
that's a finite construction if I had
sent to Microsoft I've got the new iPod
touch it's so much better than your Zune
they would've said can we see it what
does it do react react react react
finite players play to be bet to beat
the people around them infinite players
play to be better than themselves to
wake up every single day and say how can
we make our company a better version of
itself today than it was yesterday how
can we create a product this week that's
better than the product we created last
week we also have to play the intimate
game it's not about being ranked number
one it's not about having more followers
on Twitter than your friends it's not
about outdoing anyone it's about how to
outdo yourself it's not about selling
more books or getting more
ten views than somebody else it's about
how to make sure that the work that
you're producing is better than you work
you produced before you are your
competition and that is what ensures you
stay in the game the longest and that is
what ensures you find joy because the
joy comes not from comparison but from
advancement when are you at your best
I'm at my best when I'm around people
who believe what I believe I know it
seems silly but I try very very hard to
sort of stack the deck and to put myself
in a position of strength so for example
you know somebody asked me just
yesterday have you ever had sort of a
bad you know engagement unless thinking
myself I'm like not really but it's not
because I'm some sort of sort of genius
understanding anything like that it's
because I stack the deck it's because I
want to be there I want to be around
people who want me there in other words
if I'm somebody's tenth choice and like
you know I'll probably turn it down
whereas if I'm the first choice they
really want me there and so I'm more
likely to have a good engagement they're
supportive of me I'm supportive of them
and so yeah Matz was like when I stack
the deck when I choose to be in an
environment where where my strengths are
are there Nelson Mandela is a
particularly special case study in the
leadership world because he is
universally regarded as a great leader
you can take other personalities and
depending on the nation you go to we
have different opinions about other
personalities but Nelson Mandela across
the world is universally regarded as a
great leader he was actually the son of
a tribal chief and he was asked one day
how did you learn to be a great leader
and he responded that he would go with
his father to tribal meetings and he
remembers two things when his father
would meet with other elders one they
would always sit in a circle and to his
father was always the last to speak you
will be told your whole life that you
need to learn to listen I would say that
you need to learn to be the last to
speak I see it in boardrooms every day
of the week even people who consider
themselves good leaders who may actually
be decent leaders will walk into a room
and say here's the problem here's what I
think but I'm interested in your opinion
let's go around the room it's too late
the skill to hold your opinions to
yourself until everyone has spoken does
two things
one it gives everybody else the feeling
that they have been heard it give me it
gives everyone else the ability to feel
that they have contributed and two you
get the benefit of hearing what
everybody else has to think before you
render your opinion the skill is really
to keep your opinions to yourself if you
agree with somebody don't nod yes if you
disagree with somebody don't not know
simply sit there take it all in and the
only thing you're allowed to do is ask
questions so that you can understand
what they mean and why they have the
opinion that they have you must
understand from where they are speaking
why they have the opinion they have not
just what they are saying and at the end
you will get your turn
it sounds easy it's not practice being
the last to speak
that's what Nelson Mandela did every
decision we make in our lives as
individuals or as organizations is a
piece of communication it's our way of
saying something about who we are and
what we believe this is why authenticity
matters this is why you have to say and
do the things you actually believe
because the things you say and do are
symbols of who you are and we look for
those symbols so we can find people who
believe what we believe our very
survival depends on it so if you're
putting out false symbols you will
attract people to their symbols but you
won't be able to form trust with them
this is what Tiger Woods did to us he
lied he lied he told us what he thought
we wanted to hear and it was great and
we were drawn to it and all that's what
kind of like that idea of that sort of
the good guy were drawn to it until we
found out it was a lie he could have
been the bad boy of golf he could have
had all the same endorsement and had a
fantastic career and still been hailed
as one of the great athletes of our day
but he didn't he chose to lie good luck
forming trust again tiger we don't
believe you
we don't trust you the goal of putting
something out there if you say what you
believe and you do what you believe you
will attract people who believe what you
believe if you go to one of your friends
and you say to one of your friends how
would you like me to dress so that
you'll like me better how would you want
me to address you how do you want to
speak so that you like me more right
your friends are gonna look at me like
what are you talking about yeah come on
come on come on what should I wear so
that you'll find me more appealing and
how would you like me to speak to you
something you'll like me more and your
friends are gonna tell you just be
yourself that's why I like you I don't
just be yourself now think about what we
do in industry what we do we do market
research and we don't we ask the
customers what kind of things the way
what style should we speak to you how
should we decorate our cells what kind
of things are you drawn to so that we
can do those things do you like us more
it's just as ridiculous it's just as
ridiculous organizations should say and
do the things they actually believe and
they will attract people who believe
what they believe or they can choose to
lie and at the slightest hint that they
might be lying cynicism sets in and
people start saying I'm not sure I can
trust these guys because there's not a
lot of consistency in all the things
which means they can't have a very
strong belief set or they're lying to me
and we call them inauthentic the entire
process of asking other people who we
should be is inauthentic that's
hilarious to me all these positioning
studies we do are inherent we're going
to do a study to find out from people so
we can be more authentic that's
hilarious
say and do what you actually believe in
the symbols you put out there the things
you say and the things you do those red
hats are ways that people can find you
what you'll have the ability to do as
designers is create those symbols and
allow people to use those things to say
something about who they are work for
companies work for clients work for
people who you believe what they believe
show up and feel a part of something
bigger than yourself and your part is to
put what they believe into pictures and
words and symbols and graphics so that
other people can use those things to say
something about who they are people
could Harley Davidson logos on their
body to say something about who they are
corporate logo ain't no Procter &
Gamble's tattooed on anybody's on
because Harley means something they
stand for something people put that
tattoo and they're not to tell you that
they own a motorcycle they put that
tattoo there to tell you something about
themselves do you ever see anybody with
a Mac laptop with sticker over that
beautiful shining Apple ain't never
gonna happen then how will you know who
I am you ever see anybody with a PC
break out the Windex to clean out their
computer Mac people have you ever seen a
dirty Mac doesn't exist does not exist
why because it's Who I am
these are symbols we use the companies
that are crystal clear and what they
believe and their discipline and how
they do it they're consistent what they
do and everything they say and
everything they do serves as a symbol of
the set of values at least we use those
symbols to say something about who we
are we surround ourselves with the
people and the products and the brands
that say something about who we are and
when we can find the people who believe
what we believe
we're weirdly drawn to them because our
very survival depends on it we need it
and so the more you can give of yourself
the more you can give of what you
believe the more you can discipline with
discipline saying boo and do the things
you actually believe strange things
start to happen what are your thoughts
and what's your approach on finding and
building upon passions passion is not an
actionable word it's correct you know
that those who do the things the
passionate about do better but it's not
helpful advice and so the question is
where does passion come from passion is
a result passion is an energy
passion is the feeling you have when
you're engaged in something that you
love passion is the feeling you have
that
you would probably do this for free you
know and you can't believe somebody pays
you to do it you know and I think we
mistake that passion is something we do
in our private lives but it shouldn't be
done you know in our careers for example
and I'm a firm believer that you are who
you are and anybody who says I'm
different home and I and the work in one
of those two places you're lying and the
goal is to make everything you do in
home and it work something that you have
excitement to do so how do you find the
things that you're excited to do well
it's actually easier than you think what
are the things that you love to do what
are the things that you would do for
free you know how can you recreate that
feeling and and be papered so what are
the things that I do in the weekend
right I love I'm very involved in the
art world I love to go to museums and
galleries but I love to go see dance and
performances because I want to see how
others are interpreting the world so
that inspires me new ideas new thoughts
new ways of looking at the world are
things that interest me privately and I
seek it out and pay money for it right
so does that mean I have to have a
career in the arts
no it means I have to have a career
where new ideas are explored where
people are experimenting and trying
things out and I have to explore new
ideas and try things out and I'm just as
excited to go to work every day as I am
just you know go do something on a
Saturday night and so the idea of
finding your passion is ironically
simple because you should be doing stuff
that you enjoy sometimes what is the
stuff that you enjoy and then what stuff
you love who the people you love in what
are this what they all have in common
how do you explain when things don't go
as we assumed or better how do you
explain when others are able to achieve
things that seems to defy all of the
assumptions for example why is Apple so
innovative year after year after year
after year they're more innovative than
all their competition and yet they're
just a computer company they're just
like everyone else they had the same
access to the same talent the same
agencies the same consultants the same
media then why is it that they seem to
have something different why is it that
Martin Luther King led the civil rights
movement he wasn't the only man who
suffered in a pre-civil Rights America
and he certainly wasn't the only great
orator of the day why him and why is it
that the Wright brothers were able to
figure out control powered man flight
when there were certainly other teams
were better qualified that are funded
and they didn't achieve powered man
flight and the Wright brothers beat them
to it there's something else at play
here about three and a half years ago I
made a discovery and this discovery
profoundly changed my view on how I
thought the world worked and it even
profoundly changed the way in which I
operate in it
as it turns out there's a pattern as it
turns out all the great and inspiring
leaders and organizations in the world
whether it's Apple or Martin Luther King
or the Wright brothers they all think
act and communicate the exact same way
and it's the complete opposite to
everyone else all I did was codify it
and it's probably the world's simplest
idea I call it the Golden Circle
why how what this little idea explains
why some organizations and some leaders
are able to inspire where others aren't
let me define the terms really quickly
every single person every single
organization on the planet knows what
they do 100 percent some know how they
do it would you call it your
differentiating value proposition or
your proprietary process or your USP but
very very few people who are
organizations know why they do what they
do and by why I don't mean to make a
profit that's a result it's always a
result why why I mean what's your
purpose what's your cause what's your
belief why does your organization exist
why'd you get out of bed in the morning
and why should anyone care well as a
result the way we think the way we act
the way we communicate is from the
outside in it's obvious we go from the
clearest thing to the fuzziest thing but
the inspired leaders in the inspire or
inspired organizations regardless of
their size regardless of their industry
all think act to communicate from the
inside out let me give you an example I
use Apple because they're easy to
understand and everybody gets it if
Apple were like everyone else a
marketing message from them might sound
like this we make great computers
they're beautifully designed simple to
use and user friendly want to buy one
and that's how most of us communicate
that's how most marketing is done it's
almost sales done and that's how most of
us communicate interpersonally we say
what we do we say how we're different or
how we better and we expect some sort of
behavior I purchase a vote something
like that here's our new law firm we
have the best lawyers were the biggest
clients we have you know we always
perform for our clients do business with
us here's our new car it gets great gas
mileage it has you know leather seats by
our car but it's uninspiring here's how
Apple actually communicates everything
we do we believe in challenging the
status quo we believe in thinking
differently the way we challenge the
status quo is by making our products
beautifully designed simple to use and
user friendly we just happen to make
great computers want to buy one totally
different right you ready to buy a
computer from me all I did was reverse
the order of the information what it
proves to us is that people don't buy
what you do people buy why you do it
people don't buy what you do they buy
why you do it this explains why every
single person in this room is perfectly
comfortable buying a computer from Apple
but we're also perfectly comfortable
buying an mp3 player from Apple or a
phone from Apple or a DVR from Apple but
as I said before Apple is just a
computer company there's nothing that
distinguishes them structurally for many
of their competitors their competitors
are all equally qualified to make all of
these products in fact I tried a few
Gateway came out with flat-screen TVs
they're eminently qualified to make
flat-screen tvs they've been making some
flat-screen monitors for years nobody
bought one Dell came out with mp3
players and PDAs and they make great
quality products and they can make
perfectly well design products and
nobody bought one in fact talking about
it now we can't even imagine buying an
mp3 player from Dell why would you buy
an mp3 player from a computer company
but we do it every day people don't buy
what you do they buy why you do it the
goal is not to do business with anybody
with everybody who needs what you have
the goal is to do business with people
who believe what you believe
here's the best part none of what I'm
telling you is my opinion it's all
grounded in the tenets of biology not
psychology biology if you look at a
cross-section of the human brain looking
from the top down what you see is the
human brain is actually broken into
three major components that correlate
perfectly with the golden circle our
newest brain our Homo Sapien brain our
neocortex corresponds with the what
level the neocortex is responsible for
all of our rational and analytical
thought and language the middle two
sections to make up our limbic brains
and our limbic brains responsible for
all of our feelings like trust and
loyalty it's also responsible for all
human behavior all decision-making and
it has no capacity for language in other
words when we communicate from the
outside in yes people can understand
vast amounts of complicated information
like features and benefits and facts and
figures
it just doesn't drive behavior when we
communicate from the inside out we're
talking directly to the part of the
brain that controls behavior and then we
allow people to rationalize it with the
tangible things we say and do this is
where gut decisions come from you know
sometimes you can give somebody all the
facts and figures in his I know what all
the facts and details say but it just
doesn't feel right why would we use that
verb it doesn't feel right because the
part of the brain that controls
decision-making doesn't control language
and the best we can muster up is I don't
know it just doesn't feel right where
sometimes you say you're leading with
your heart or you're leading with your
soul well I hate to break it to you
those aren't other body parts
controlling your behavior it's all
happening here in your limbic brain the
part of the brain that controls
decision-making and not language but if
you don't know why you do what you do
and people respond to why you do what
you do then how will anybody help you
ever get people to vote for you or buy
something from you or more importantly
be loyal and want to be a part of what
it is what you bet you do
again the goal is not just as to sell
people who need what you have the goal
is to sell to people who believe what
you believe the goal is not just to hire
people who need a job it's to hire
people who believe what you believe I
always say that you know
this if you if you if you and hire
people just because they can do a job
they'll work for your money but he hire
people who believe what you believe they
working with blood and sweat and tears
and no era nowhere else is there a
better example of this thing with the
Wright brothers most people don't know
about Samuel Pierpont Langley and back
in the early 20th century the pursuit of
powered man flight was like the calm of
the day everybody was trying it and
Samuel Pierpont Langley had what we
assume to be the recipe for success I
mean even now you ask people why did
your product or why did your company
fail and people ways give you the Premio
same permutation of the same three
things undercapitalized
the wrong people bad market conditions
it's always the same three things so
let's explore that Samuel Pierpont
Langley was given fifty thousand dollars
by the War Department to figure out this
flying machine money was no problem he
held a seat at Harvard and worked at the
Smithsonian and was extremely
well-connected he knew all the big minds
of the day he hired the best minds money
could find and the market conditions
were fantastic the New York Times
followed him around everywhere and
everyone was rooting for Langley and how
can we've never heard of Samuel Pierpont
Langley a few hundred miles away in
Dayton Ohio Orville and Wilbur Wright
they had none of what we consider to be
the recipe for success they had no money
they paid for their dream with the
proceeds from their bicycle shop not a
single person on the Wright brothers
team had a college education
not even Orville or Wilbur and the New
York Times followed them around nowhere
the difference was Orville and Wilbur
were driven by a caused by a purpose by
a belief they believed that if they
could figure out this flying machine
it'll change the course of the world
Samuel Pierpont Langley was different he
wanted to be rich and he want to be
famous he was in pursuit of the result
he was in pursuit of the riches and lo
and behold look what happened the people
who believed in the Wright brothers
dream worked with them with blood and
sweat and tears the others just worked
for the paycheck and they tell stories
of how every time the Wright brothers
went out they would have to take five
sets of parts because that's how many
times they would crash before they came
in for supper and eventually on December
17th 1903 the Wright brothers took
flight and no one was there to even
experience it we found out about it a
few days later and further proof that
Langley was motivated by the wrong thing
the day the Wright brothers took flight
he quit he could have said that's an
amazing discovery guys and I will
improve upon your technology but he
didn't he wasn't first he didn't get
rich he didn't get famous so he quit
people don't buy what you do they buy
why you do it and if you talk about what
you believe you will attract those who
what you believe well why is it
important to attract those who believe
what you believe something called the
law of diffusion of innovation and if
you don't know the law you definitely
know the terminology the first two and a
half percent of our population are our
innovators the next thirteen and a half
percent of our population are our early
adopters the next 34% are your early
majority your late majority and your
laggards the only reason these people by
touch-tone phones is cuz you can't buy
rotary phones anymore we all sit at
various places at various times on the
scale but the law of diffusion of
innovation tells us is that if you want
mass-market success or mass-market
acceptance of an idea you cannot have it
until you achieve this tipping point
between 15 and 18 percent market
penetration and then the system tips and
I love asking businesses what's your
conversion on new business and I'd love
to tell you oh it's about 10% proudly
well you can trip over 10% of the
customers we all have about 10% who just
get it that's why we describe them all
right that's like that gut feeling oh
they just get it the problem is how do
you find the ones that just get it
before you're doing business with them
versus the ones who don't get it
so it's this here this little gap that
you have to close as Jeffrey Moore calls
of crossing the chasm because you see
the early majority will not try
something until someone else has tried
it first and these guys the innovators
in the early adopters they're
comfortable making those gut decisions
they're more comfortable making those
intuitive decisions that are driven by
what they believe about the world and
not just what product is available these
are the people who stood on line for six
hours to buy an iPhone when they first
came out when you could have just walked
into the store the next week and bought
one off the shelf these are the people
who spend $40,000 on flat-screen TVs
when they first came out even though the
technology was substandard
and by the way they didn't do it because
the technology was so great they did it
for themselves it's because they wanted
to be first people don't buy what you do
they buy why you do it and what you do
simply proves what you believe in fact
people will do the things that prove
what they believe the reason that person
bought the iPhone on the first in the
first six hours stood in sync in line
for six hours was because what they
believe about the world and how they
wanted everybody to see them they were
first people don't buy what you do they
buy why you do it so let me give you a
famous example a famous failure and
famous success of the law of diffusion
of innovation first the famous failure
it's a commercial example as we said
before a second ago the recipe for
success is money in the right people in
the right market conditions right you
should have success then look at TiVo
from the time TiVo came out about eight
or nine years ago to this current day
they are the single highest quality
product on the market
hands down there is no dispute they were
extremely well-funded market conditions
were fantastic I mean we use TiVo as a
verb like TiVo stuff on my piece of junk
Time Warner DVR all the time Patito is a
commercial failure they've never made
money and when they went IPO their stock
was at about 30 or 40 dollars then
plummeted and it's never traded above
ten in fact I don't think that's even
trade about six except for a couple of
little spikes because you see Matt Ito
launched their product they told us all
what they had they said we have a
product that pauses live TV skips
commercials rewinds live TV and
memorizes your viewing habits without
you even asking and the cynical majority
said we don't believe you we don't need
it we don't like it you're scaring us
what if they had said if you're the kind
of person who likes to have total
control over every aspect of your life
boy do we have a product for you it
pauses live TV skips commercials
memorizes your viewing habits etc etc
people don't buy what you do they buy
why you do it and what you do simply
serves as the proof of what you believe
now let me give you a successful example
of the law of diffusion of innovation in
the summer of 1963 250,000 people showed
up on the mall in Washington to hear dr.
King speak they sent out no invitations
and there was no website to check the
date how do you do that well dr. King
wasn't the only man in America who was
the who's a great orator he wasn't the
only man America who suffered in a
pre-civil Rights America in fact some of
his ideas were bad but he had a gift he
didn't go around telling people what
needed to change in America you know he
went around and told people what he
believed I believe I believe I believe
he told people and people who believed
what he believed took his cause and they
made it their own and they told people
and some of those people created
structures to get the word out even more
people and lo and behold 250,000 people
showed up on the right day on the right
time to hear him speak how many of them
showed up for him zero they showed up
for themselves it's what they believed
about America that got them to travel on
a bus for eight hours to stand in the
Sun in Washington for in the middle of
August it's what they believed and it
wasn't about black versus white 25% of
the audience was white dr. King believed
that there were two types of laws in
this world those that are made by a
higher authority Authority and those
that are made by man and not until all
the laws that are made by man are
consistent with the laws that are made
by the higher authority will
we live in a just world it just so
happens at the civil rights movement was
the perfect thing to help him bring his
cause to life
we followed not him not for him but for
ourselves and by the way he gave the I
have a dream speech not the I have a
planned speech listen to politicians now
with the comprehensive 12-point plans
are not inspiring anybody because there
were leaders and there are those who
lead leaders hold a position of power or
authority but those who lead inspire us
with other individuals or organizations
we follow those who lead because we have
to but because we want to we follow
those who lead not for them but for
ourselves and it's those who start with
Y that have the ability to inspire those
around them or find others who inspire
them thank you very much thank you guys
so much for watching I made this video
because Lex venta Herrick asked me to so
if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you would like me to profile next please
leave it down the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I just love to
know which clip resonated the most with
you today what did Simon say that had
the biggest impact what change you're
gonna make to your life for business
after watching this video please leave
it down the comments below I'm not gonna
join in the discussion thank you so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
decision-making is a process right the
question is what filters are you using
to make decisions are you making
decisions based on the financial rewards
are you making decisions based on how
easy the work will be I mean I remember
in college you know they would give you
this book where they all the students
would rate the classes and they would
rate things like how easy the class was
and how you know how much they liked the
professor and you know the first year I
picked all my classes based on it
workload and I think everything a low
workload you know and pretty bored
didn't work very hard which is fine but
nothing was dynamic and nothing really
excited me and I thank goodness learned
that and so this second year I picked
all my classes by professor rating
regardless of the workload so every
class I had I had these dynamic amazing
incredible human beings passing on their
knowledge and you were excited to work
hard for them you know and so again what
the question is what if the filters were
using and so if you're only chasing the
mighty dollar then you will have jobs
that'll pay you a little more than the
last but you enjoying yourself and I
talked to a guy recently he was in he's
in bad shape
like he really hates his life and he's
really depressed he doesn't what to do
and so we're going through all his old
jobs you know and I said to me a job
that you've loved and he had it every
single job he's chosen out of college he
picked because of the money and it's
something offered him or somewhere else
he took it you know regardless and and
and the amazing thing is he plateaued
because if you're only chasing the
result if you're only chasing the thing
that makes it easy right then eventually
you will get bored or they'll get bored
of you right and you plateau in other
words chasing the almighty dollar if
that's your only thing it eventually
flattens out whereas if you're chasing
the thing that excites you the human
beings to be around the work that
excites you the stuff that you know you
know you you can get passionate about
you know the the irony is is you'll
actually make way way more right because
you're excited and I appreciate your
excitement they reward you excitement
you're better at your work because you
want to work harder and all of that
stuff you don't have to strain to work
harder so decision making is simply a
matter of filters you know and so I've
made decisions in my life that I would
rather be happy than right I'd rather do
good then then get rich and and so the
decisions I make put me in positions
where when I leave any engagement when I
leave any meeting I feel that I've
contributed right
rare are the times anymore where you
walk by going just think of the money
just like money think of the money you
know I because I doesn't feel nice and
and the experience I have
I don't enjoy traveling time and I don't
try to travel home we have an amazing
experience I am looking forward to
getting there I'm excited when I leave
you know so it's just decision make
decision making is just a matter of what
filters you use and if you're if you're
good about keeping those filters up and
clear then
then make a decision I don't judge
anybody by how if they choose to use
different filters these are just the
filters I choose to live my life you
know not right or wrong just those are
my decisions
you know that's my filter how can you
help the human race how can you help the
human race human species progress
I'm not joking either this is something
I think we all have to be aware of at
the end of the day the human animals are
social animal and our very survival
depends on our ability to form
communities to form cultures
what's a community what's a culture it's
a group of people with a common set of
values and beliefs right what's a
country it's a group of people with a
common set of values and beliefs
what's a company it should be a group of
people with a common set of values and
beliefs when we're surrounded by people
who believe what we believe something
remarkable happens Trust emerges and
make no mistake of it tresses of feeling
a distinctly human feeling you know we
all have friends we're total screw-ups
NIT we still trust them right Trust is
not a check with simply doing everything
you say you're going to do doesn't it
does not mean people will inherently
trust you it just means you're reliable
we need trust right we need trust when
we're surrounded by people who believe
what we believe and trust starts to
emerge and we trust them and they trust
us we're more willing to take risks
we're more willing to experiment which
requires failure we're more willing to
explore and go somewhere that no one has
ever gone before with the confidence
that if we fail if we trip over if we
turn our backs that those within our
community those who we trust and who
trust us will look after us while we're
gone we'll pick us up when we fall over
we'll help us when we're hurt our very
survival depends on it
we're not good at everything we're not
good by ourselves you know my said you
have to go fight a saber-toothed tiger
by yourself odds are Tiger one you zero
it's not gonna go very well but if you
go out as a group we're pretty damn
amazing and the reason is is because we
all have our strengths and we all have
our certain weaknesses and the goal is
not to fix your weaknesses the goal is
to amplify your strengths and surround
yourself with the people who can do what
you can't do but it's not just based on
skills and an application and experience
it's based on what you believe it's
based on what you believe you see simply
being good at something and having
somebody else being good what you're no
good at doesn't mean you will trust each
other trust the sense of trust comes
from the sense of common values and
common beliefs improve it how many of
you from New York okay
bunch of you are you friends with
everybody in New York why not why not
but when you go to Los Angeles and you
meet someone from New York you like hey
I'm from New York and your best friends
right and when you go to France you know
you're on the Paris Metro minding your
own business
you hear an American acts behind you you
turn around and say hey where you from
they say Los Angeles you're like hey I'm
from New York and you're best friends
because when you're surrounded by people
who don't believe what you believe when
you're in a strange environment where
you don't feel comfortable you look for
anyone who may share some of the same
values and pleats that you have and you
start to form a very real and very
intense bond with them simply because
you know that they have a basic
understanding of how you grew up with
the things that you care about or the
life that you live back home well the
same is true when we go to work do we
want to go to work with people who
understand us who believe what we
believe we have a similar view of the
world has nothing to do with their
opinions and the differences that we
share that's good that's called
diversity that's called advantages to
problem-solving which is we can all look
at the same thing from a different angle
and come up with solutions what I'm
talking about is why should you help
each other in the first place what are
you in pursuit of now the question is is
what creates that sense of values and
believes what creates that sense of
trust right are very human instinct we
know how to find people who believe what
we believe our survival depends on it
we're biologically gifted with this idea
and I ask you to go out in the street
and find all the people who believe what
you believe you know exactly what to do
you're gonna strike up conversations
you're gonna start talking to people and
you'll either you'll have a good feeling
about them or you won't either you'll
have chemistry whatever that means or
you don't sometimes it's quick sometimes
it's slow but we know how to do it it's
called making friends it's called dating
it's called networking we have the
innate ability to do it true story
there was a former Undersecretary of
Defense who was invited to give a speech
at a large conference about a thousand
people and he was standing on the stage
with his cup of coffee and a Styrofoam
cup giving his prepare to march with his
PowerPoint behind him he took a sip of
his coffee and he smiled and he looked
down at the Cuffy and then he went
off-script and he said you know last
year I spoke at this exact same
conference last year I was still the
undersecretary and when I spoke here
last year they flew me here business
class and when I arrived at the airport
there was somebody waiting for me to
take me to my hotel and they took me to
my hotel and they've already checked me
in and they just took me up to my room
and the next morning I came downstairs
and there was someone waiting in the
lobby to greet me and they drove me to
this here same venue they took me
through the back entrance and took me
into the green room and handed me a
coffee cup of coffee in a beautiful
ceramic cup he says I no longer the
undersecretary I flew here coach I took
a taxi to my hotel and I checked myself
in when I came down to lobby this
morning I took another taxi to this
venue I came in the front door and found
my way backstage and when I
someone do you have any coffee he
pointed to the coffee machine in the
corner and I poured myself a cup of
coffee into this here Styrofoam cup he
says the lesson is the ceramic cup was
never meant for me it was meant for the
position I held I deserved a Styrofoam
cup remember this as you gain fame as
you gain fortune as you gain position
and seniority people will treat you
better they will hold doors open for you
they will get you a cup of tea and
coffee without you even asking they will
call you sir and ma'am and they will
give you stuff none of that stuff is
meant for you that stuff is meant for
the position you hold it is meant for
the level that you have achieved of
leader or success or whatever you want
to call it but you will always deserve a
Styrofoam cup remember that remember
that lesson of humility and gratitude
you can accept all the free stuff you
can accept all the perks absolutely you
can enjoy them but just be grateful for
them and know that they're not for you
I remember getting off the Acela I took
the Acela from New York to Washington DC
and I got off the train like everybody
else and I was walking down the platform
like everyone else and I walked past
general norty Schwartz who used to be
the chief of staff of the United States
Air Force the head of the Air Force and
here I did you see a guy in a suit
slapping his own suitcase down the
platform just like me and just a couple
months ago he was flying on private jets
and an entourage and other people
carried his like luggage but he no
longer held a position and so now he got
to drag his own suitcase and never did
it sort of remind me more that none of
us deserve the perks that we get we all
deserve a Styrofoam cup raise your
standard Apple at the course his core
value is that we believe that people
with passion
not one drop of myself work depends on
your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten Rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details